[Musik]
das ist die nackte waschen sharp
russische skifahrerin luftfahrt
ingenieurin und internationale maklerin
blöcke
energie das neueste lukrative
geschäftsidee england an superreiche
russen verkaufen sie macht ihren kinder
auf schnellstem weg reif für die hohe
gesellschaft und die besten schulen
englands
[Musik]
china ist gerade aus moskau hergeflogen
je wohlhabender russischer klient will
dass seine kinder eine gute britische
schule besuchen
unsere klienten wollen dass ihre kinder
auf diese schulen gehen und freundin im
besten britischen familien
in russland gibt es niemanden der mit
elite schulen zusammenarbeitet oder
kinder darauf vorbereitet
es gibt nur
diener arbeitet mit dem bildungsberater
charles bonas zusammen hallo die na wie
geht's
schön dich zu sehen
russisch englisch sogar arabisch
englisch
diener plant für die kinder ihrer
klienten einen maßgeschneiderten kurs
damit sie den englischen adel
kennenlernen und sich nahtlos einfügen
können
ihrem kind die teilnahme an einem
englischen mentorenprogramm zu
ermöglichen ist eine wahre investition
in ihre zukunft sie
werden auf die probe gestellt aber ihre
anstrengungen werden
sie bleiben das wochenende über bei der
familie wir haben spezialisierte
mentoren für die vorbereitung von
ausländischen kindern für die aufnahme
in der schule
nachmittags warten spaßige aktivitäten
zb
golf tennis
diener weiß dass schul vermittler in
nahost und asien nach kräften versuchen
kinder in die besten schulen
großbritanniens zu bringen
der konkurrenzkampf ist brutal
viele britische schulen haben eine
obergrenze für den anteil ausländischer
schüler man tritt gegen kinder aus asien
an die für die nutzung dieses systems
geradezu gezüchtet werden
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass sie bei einer
britischen familie leben und unsere
lebensweise hier in england kennen
war kein geld für die renovierung dieser
wand mehr dar den die nada das ist ein
rustikales landhaus wir sind hier in
england nicht russland
an das statement authentisch und urig
[Musik]
die naz sohn ivan das macht eine der
besten schulen englands westminster
heute oder der für seine schule die wahl
nach westminster zu bekommen war
schwierig die nutzer hier eine
marktlücke
das machte schnell die runde dass ivan
in westminster aufgenommen worden
direkt aus moskau ohne eine englische
schule zu besuchen so fängt alles an
russland ist es gerade angesagt seine
kinder nach england zu schicken wer sich
leisten kann
man macht sich bei einer über die deren
kinder nicht nach england gehen lustig
als diener beim wettbewerb ankommt ist
die wand rennen leider schon vorbei
was nicht ist da
hinten da ja ich habe es total verpasst
als ehemalige skiläuferin kein diener
die leidenschaft für den sport gut
verstehen
wie ihre klienten investiert sie jedoch
viel geld in events schulbesuch ja
akademische leistung hat vor angst meine
eltern sagten immer man solle sein hirn
anstrengen um geld zu verdienen
man konnte jeden sport kennenlernen
erst liefern jetzt rudern was im
westminster ganz groß geschrieben wird
man muss abwägen ob die zeit investition
für das training zwei stunden auf dem
eisigen fluss das wirklich wert ist
seid ihr durch können wir gehen mir ist
kalt
im internet stores at 6 12 j digby
dealer den elfjährigen sohn nathan sowie
wassili den stiefsohn ihres klienten
dabei sie sollen lernen den richtigen
eindruck zu hinterlassen
der ehemalige offizier nigel hätten
peyton leitet den kurs
wir werden ihnen polo näher bringen das
ist hier ein sehr beliebtes spiel
als ich damit anfing war ich noch jünger
als sie aber meine mutter trainierte das
polo team von simbabwe und ihre vier
söhne waren phasen ihr eigenes polo team
ich fing also nahezu damit an bevor ich
laufen könnte
du wirst hier also polo kennenlernen und
muss entscheiden ob du es spielen willst
oder nicht
es ist ein interessantes spiel kein
spiel für könige und königinnen
man könnte sagen wer polo spielt gehört
zur gehobenen gesellschaft
willkommen im volkspark ich bin schon
mal geritten
wirklich wie oft
dreimal bisher ok und nathan einmal für
zehn minuten ok also nicht viel
erfahrung mit pferden ja ein polo
spieler braucht robuste kniehohe stiefel
und einen guten herrn
knieschoner sind auch wichtig denn es
ist der schnellste ballsport der welt
und noch dazu ein kontaktsport
ohne gute knieschoner bleibt von den
knien nicht viel übrig
hin und wieder verletzen sich spieler
leider auch
bereit
die diener hat ivan mitgebracht er soll
zeigen was er beim polo kann er ist erst
14 aber seine internationale erziehung
ist unübersehbar
ich bringe ihm ganz bewusst verschiedene
kulturen näher
die ersten jahre in russland dann in den
vereinigten staaten
dann dachte ich mir britische kultur
wäre noch eine tolle ergänzung für
unsere klienten wollen sich der kultur
anpassen
sie wollen nicht als die neuen russen
oder neureich wahrgenommen werden
die besten vertreter einer kultur und
deren kinder kennenzulernen ist ihnen
viel wert
das ist passiert der hier sagt hallo
pass nicht hallo bindung aufbauen
davis pferd
du musst wie halte ich an
dazu kommen wir gleich
genauso und umdrehen
du hast die kontrolle drehen sagt loos
passen
sie treffen den ball gut beeindruckend
den schläger zu benutzen ist der
schwierigste die sind aus argentinien ja
die habe ich mitgebracht wirklich eine
schöne kehrte ivan wird ganz anders
erzogen als diener damals
in meiner kindheit durften wir nicht mit
ausländern reden das hat die ernste
folgen
ich wuchs in einer geschlossenen stadt
im ural auf
dass eltern arbeiteten als physiker an
streng geheimen atomwaffenprogramm
die anlage war im wald versteckt
die stadt war wie ein eigenes land
inklusive einer grenze die rund um die
uhr bewacht worden
sie waren nicht frei gemacht die mit
ihrer familie hatten ein gutes leben
anders als die meisten russen genossen
sind gutes gehalt und hohe
lebensstandard bediener machte einen
abschluss als luftfahrt ingenieur in der
zusammenbruch des kommunistischen
regimes anfang der neunziger jahre
beendete dieses bequeme leben jedoch die
perestroika ein albtraum für uns
klar physiker mussten kartoffeln anbauen
damit etwas zu essen da war es wurden
keine gehälter bezahlt
es hat ein einjähriges kind und wusste
nicht was ich tun soll
verkauften alles arbeiten nahezu umsonst
die regierung schuldet uns ein
jahresgehalt wir mussten das brot mit
essensmarken kaufen
in der zeitung sah ich eine
stellenausschreibung als büroleiterin
nach drei monaten wechselte ich zu einer
anderen firma und wurde schließlich zu
einer der führenden immobilienmakler
rinnen in moskau
einige jahre später so diene als
erfolgreiche geschäftsfrau nach
so laufen alle erfolgsgeschichten in
russland istanbul ein gerät ins
straucheln lässt sich davon aber nicht
beirren hat keine angst und bleibt am
ball so entsteht vermögen echtes
vermögen
ich gebe dir eine waffe
nein warum
chinas dienste als vermittlerin für
superreiche haben ihren preis wir sind
ziemlich teuer
familien uns aber fragen warum wir
teurer als andere anbieter sind sage ich
meinem team in russland dass sie dann
eben keine klärten für uns werden wenn
sie unsere preise in frage stellen
sie verstehen scheinbar nicht dass die
vorbereitung der kinder das wertvollste
überhaupt ist
sagte sie mit einer freundin
und rivalin hause
sie wissen jetzt wie man mit pferden und
waffen umgeht nathan und wasili sollten
sich daher gut in die ländliche kulisse
englands einfügen
wir haben etwas chaos in ihrem
schlafzimmer gemacht handtücher auf dem
boden durch gewählte betten
ich gehe mit ihnen durch wie es aussehen
sollte wenn man in jemandes haus lebt
und nicht im hotel das sie
wahrscheinlich eher gewohnt sind
[Musik]
wir haben hier karls gemacht
unsere klienten kommen aus aller welt
wie ihr leben alles mögliche
einige kinder wurden von klein auf zu
sehr verwöhnt wodurch sie natürlich auf
die schiefe bahn geraten sind dahra
hoffnung und glauben sie müssten nur mit
den fingern schnippen alles wird für sie
erledigt
wir bringen ihnen bei dass sie
irgendwann vielleicht nicht mehr diesen
luxus haben könnten warum auch immer zum
beispiel wenn das öl oder das gas
versiegt was dann unabänderliches
nach dem baden
kurz spülen
der kurs gipfel ende juni werden auch
umfassende akademische förderung ob es
für einen platz in einer eliteschule
reicht
[Musik]
diener caro war hilft kindern aus
russland an englische eliteschulen zu
kommen
ihr sohn ivan besucht westminster
bevor sie nach moskau fliegt clan sie
waren sie wieder zeit miteinander
verbringen können
wir gehen es beim rudern aus
wir wurden mit
anderen partnern
stangen rudern
ich kannte das englische wort nicht nach
nicht
ich kenne nicht alle wörter solltest du
sollte ich aber ich hatte nie die chance
nach westminster zu gehen
für den herrn dass trüffel risotto guten
appetit danke wir müssen jetzt für
ostern planen vor ist wir wurden zum
skifahren in die schweiz eingeladen oder
wir fliegen in vereinigten staaten wenn
du skifahren höchst und nicht rudern
ich hab dir gesagt vom liebling 13 bis
19 liebling du hast es mir nebenbei
gesagt ich brauche das per mail
sag mir auch was wir in deinem
geburtstag machen ich hätte dich gerne
für drei tage in russland an deinem
geburtstag
ich bleibe hier
nicht streiten würde
[Musik]
die diener trifft nathan vassili und
ihren vater boris einen bekannten
russischen geschäftsmann doch es will
verschiedene schulen besichtigen heute
besuchen sie store in buckinghamshire
in der vergangenheit waren die
eliteschulen für die ausbildung der
herrscher familien verantwortlich was
sie kulturell geprägt hat die neuen
russen versuchen nach allen kräften die
lebensart der elite der zarenzeit
nachzuahmen wozu auch die ausbildung im
westen gehört
[Musik]
ich bin david fletcher diese familien
herum starke veränderungen erlebt von
einem autoritären staat hin zur
zügellosen kapitalismus bis hin zur
dekadenz
sie schicken ihre kinder auf britische
schulen damit sie dinge und werte kennen
lernen die über den materialismus
hinausgehen
die oligarchen haben erkannt dass sie
damit eine welt bürgerliche weitsicht
erlangen die es in russland einfach
nicht gibt
spannend ja sehr spannend merkt ihr
sport ja ich liebe fußball hast du eine
lieblingsmannschaft manchester united
ich mag eine russische mannschaft
alexej wird euch gleich auf einer
führung durch die schule begleiten
er kam in der sechsten klasse aus
russland also dachten wir er wer genau
der richtige ansprechpartner für euch da
er einen ähnlichen weg beschreitet
gut
alex du bist dran
so wurde in den 1920 er jahren gegründet
und hatte sehr namhafte schüler zum
beispiel richard branson ein milliardär
und eine berühmte persönlichkeit
wenn ihr fragen habt unterbricht mich
einfach und fragt
eine frage wie lange sich die
schulstunden hier
[Musik]
etwa 40 minuten
dienstags und donnerstags sind wir in
der kapelle
dort singen wir dann verschiedenste
lieder und versuchen uns durch übung
selbst zu verbessern
[Musik]
die jungen wurden zwar gut vorbereitet
aber ihr zuhause ist doch sehr weit
entfernt ihr mut beeindruckt mich immer
wieder sie kommen in ein fremdes land
sprechen nur ein paar worte der sprache
und müssen sich an ein anderes
bildungssystem anpassen fern der heimat
leben eine neue sprache lernen das ist
nicht einfach wie heißt ihr silly und
ich bin nathan nathan
hier wohnt die oberin sie kümmert sich
um eure gesundheit
kleinere dinge
wenn euch etwas bedrückt und die reden
wollte
sie am ende der rotzlöffel hat hier
etwas hin geklebt das muss weg
die zimmer weisen alle südwärts ihr seht
also den golfkurs
haben alle schüler laptops ja alle weil
sie das oder müssen sie sie müssen aber
spiele sind natürlich nicht erlaubt
es ist kein fünf sterne hotel aber das
soll es ja auch nicht sein
die kinder sollen schließlich nicht von
der yacht in die villa und von dort aus
wiederum direkt in eine ebenso luxuriöse
privatschule gehen
sie sollen ein halbwegs normales leben
erfahren so normal wie ein internat dem
sein kann
[Musik]
das ist was ihren
derjenige schüler und haus vorsteher der
auch jeden mittwoch mit den hunden auf
die jagd geht
ja das ist mein wams
[Musik]
das ist die südseite
recht eindrucksvoll
die jungen in ein internat biestow zu
schicken kostet boris jährlich mehr als
70.000 euro
[Musik]
großbritannien ist ein erstaunliches
land wir können menschen verschiedenster
herkunft integrieren und gerade die
schulen sind hierbei hervorragend
sie sind natürlich sehr elitär aber das
wird man wohl kaum ändern können sie
werden sogar immer elitärer den besten
sinne denn sie werden kompetenzzentren
die stipendien an brilliante und die
ledige kinder vergeben
das bringt man nur gurken sandwiches
essen und immer übertrieben höflich sind
ist eben nur ein mythos
treffen den direktor der erste eindruck
ist entscheidend
wo seid ihr in russland zu hause sein
petersburg
ihr interessiert euch also für aktuelle
politik wie steht es mit russischer
geschichte russische geschichte habe ich
selbst gelernt möglich welche periode
ist am interessantesten russland im
zweiten weltkrieg ich weiß vieles vor
allem kenne ich die panzer und flugzeuge
aus dem ersten und aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg
die oligarchen denken stark in dynasty
ihre nachfolge generationen werden
zehntausende arbeiter unter sich haben
eine englische erziehung mit fokus auf
die positiven aspekte englischer kultur
insbesondere unserer liberalen werte
unseres einfallsreichtums und
unternehmergeistes kann hier wirklich
nicht schaden
großbritannien wird eine gewaltige rolle
für die zukunft von russland spielen
ich finde das fantastisch denn diese
kinder verschmelzen die kulturen und
werden sich nicht zu kämpfen hinreißen
lassen wie wir es aktuell sehen
sie rufen einfach ihre freunde in
regierungs gremien an und nutzen sie mit
dem unfug aufzuhören
die aufnahmeprüfung machen sie sind erst
seit september im programm
die reformschritte von september bis
heute sind insofern großartig
ich denke wir können in zukunft noch
großartiges von ihnen erwarten
danke dass ihr uns getroffen haben danke
für euer interesse an der schule auf
wiedersehen danke wir hören von einander
vielen dank auf wiedersehen
in london besprechen charles und diana
den fortschritt der jungen
den halleschen nicht zusehen wie geht's
jetzt
am freitag ins tor
das war ihr erstes vorstellungsgespräch
aber sie haben sich mühe gegeben ist und
die schule hat ihnen gefallen
wirklich
boris gefällt dass sie in einem kleinen
ort ist und wie schön sie ist
aber die borussen üblich ist viel zu
weit von hitler und london entfernt
so ist das nun mal
die eltern fliegen anderthalb tage zu
ihren kindern warum stehen herre und
westminster nun mal ganz oben auf der
liste
[Musik]
die jungen weitere schulen im ganzen
land
nathan und wasili wurden unter vorbehalt
plätze in shutter haus angeboten
ein großartiges ergebnis denn sie sind
ja erst zu kurz im land
müssen sie sich auf ihre prüfungen im
januar vorbereiten wenn sie die bestehen
sind sie drin
[Musik]